members of the press continue along the
lines of if you disagree
with me then you are responsible for the
riot
uh brianna keeler from cnn who used to
be
a lot better as an anchor and she has
morphed into a sort of don lemon type
very wild-eyed leftist at this point on
cnn she
is now suggesting that senator cruz
incited the riot
as donald trump's second impeachment
trial nears there is one senator who led
the charge to challenge the electoral
college count
and enthusiastically threw his weight
behind multiple
efforts to undermine the democratic
presidential election and is now trying
to cleanse himself
of the stain of those actions cruz
didn't seem to mind the quote reckless
and irresponsible rhetoric from the
president
in fact cruz joined in speaking to
voters in georgia in early january just
days before the senate runoffs there
okay so again the idea is that anybody
who backed
trump's suggestion that the election
results ought to be challenged
they are responsible for the rise and i
think that that was wrong what cruz did
i think that it was wrong what holly did
i don't think that any of that is
responsible for the riots i believe that
adults have agency there are plenty of
adults who came and rallied with trump
and who left
in the middle of the riots or before the
riots even occurred
nonetheless again the goal of the press
here i keep saying it over and over and
over because people need to see through
the veil the press
are not honest brokers they're not even
attempting to be honest brokers here we
all know this it is perfectly obvious to
everyone
who has brain what exactly the press are
doing these are not folks who are
standing up for the institutions of our
democracy
these are folks are perfectly fine with
undermining institutions of our
democracy on a fairly regular basis
depending on who is doing the
undermining these are folks who cheered
on violence throughout the summer
and no that is not an apple store or
just comparison is that a comparison
that is an apples-to-apples comparison
it's not what about ism because some of
us condemned violence all the way
through
and yet here you have michael beschloss
the historian suggesting that america
should treat january 6th
historically like 9 11 we should
memorialize the date of the capital
insurrection just like 9 11.
he says it's like the day we almost lost
our democracy no actually it was not
i'm sorry it didn't even come close to
us losing our democracy it came close to
being an awful evil tragic incident like
the congressional baseball shooting
it was a breach of our values for sure
it was ugly
i said i think it was the ugliest public
spectacle since 9 11 in the united
states
but should we memorialize it the same
way that we memorialize the death of 3
000 americans
because a bunch of nuts and violent mob
and a violent mob was stopped by the
cops before
they could do serious damage and let's
not let's be frank about this there was
no threat to the overall democracy of
the united states you want to see an
overall threat to democracy take a look
at myanmar
but right now a military coup is in
place okay that is not the same thing
as a bunch of mob idiots storming a
capitol building
okay so never mind the uh never mind the
actual history never mind the actual
comparisons here is michael bischloss
the historian
suggesting that we should treat january
6th like 9 11 is the day we almost lost
our democracy again
this is such hyperbolic nonsense
conceivably this could have taken away
our democracy
and this is one reason why i think we
have to observe
the 6th of january every single year as
a time that we had a very close call
to remind us that we have to be
eternally vigilant because democracy
is fragile you know rachel we we observe
9 11.
we remember the fact that there were
attacks that landed
one that almost landed which was an
effort to fly an airplane
into the capital kill a lot of members
of congress
that almost happened here is a terrorist
attack that did happen
okay uh of the wait is he just calling
9118 terrorist attack that didn't happen
and that like the fact that they didn't
hit the capitol building on 911
is one of the things we remember least
about 911. the thing we remember most
about 911 is the images of planes flying
into the world trade center and taking
down both towers plus another plane
flying into the pentagon and another
plane
being crashed into a field in
pennsylvania that's that's those are the
things that i remember about 911
the the desire to turn january 6th
into a referendum on the fragility of
our democracy generally
is i think quite silly and again it
really
is more tied to what people want to
happen next it's not about what happened
on january 6th that's what people want
to happen next and the media want this
more than anything
the media more than anything want a a
crackdown
on people they dislike they want to
justify any attack
of any kind on people they dislike the
media are just over the moon about
alexander ocasio-cortez's comparison
between her alleged sexual assaulter and
ted cruz and josh halley which is
i'm sorry a morally absurd comparison
people who disagree with you politically
even if they do stuff that is cynical
and that you don't like
are not like people who tried to rape
you or who did rape you that is not the
same thing
that is not the same thing in any way
and yet we're told by monica hess the
columnist at the washington post
alexandre alcazar cortez says she was
told that trauma victims should tell
their stories as part of their healing
and that is what she did monday night in
the most compelling heartbreaking and
infuriating 60 minutes available
on any screen at any time this week
she talked about her how she found
herself questioning the motives of a law
enforcement officer who had given her
hazy instructions
on how to reach an evacuation point by
the way i will note that people are
ignoring the fact that uh during that
live stream alexander ocasio-cortez
suggested that a police officer who came
to help her might have in fact she was
suspicious that he was in fact a white
supremacist
in disguise because he was white and the
respect for police officer is going
right out the window on that one
according to monica hess aoc compared it
to a sexual harasser telling his victim
the quickest path to normalcy
would be her forgiving him or the
parents telling the child they once
abused that the mistreatment had
happened in the past
okaza cortez's whole live stream was
brave but this was the bravest part
when she cried foul on a warped view of
reconciliation in which those who stoke
the fires of anger and false belief that
fueled the attack demand
that the victims simply forgive and
forget well that's not all she did
right she compared them to rapists and
sexual assaulters but she's going to
receive the plaudits of the media in the
lifestyle section by the way
of the washington post meanwhile what is
this going to lead to
well what this is really going to lead
to is the media calling for more
crackdowns on people
with whom they disagree i mean we can
all see which way this is going what
they would like is a media
monopoly facts don't care about your
feelings and it's a fact that the ben
shapiro show is the largest conservative
podcast in the nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content